affection first algorithm design
complexity it's supposed to be like
greyed out and but okay so thank you for
the introduction that was incredibly
nice and like I can't stress enough how
excited I am to be here and how happy I
am this happening and how grateful I am
to the organizers for putting this
together and you know allowing me to
come but yeah so I'm going to be giving
two talks in succession with the break
in between so first I'll be talking
about lattice algorithms and then
they'll be talking about complexity of
lattice problems so just like with
Daniella is talk like this is a big area
so I'm just sort of gonna pick and
choose what I'm going to show you and
I'm gonna try to go as slow slowly I'm
going to try to assume no background
knowledge but for the experts in the
audience I'm also going to include a lot
of open problems I think was it Vinod
who said this that like we really know
very little about this stuff and we
really do so there are a lot of open
problems
that'll present in this talk so I think
that's all I want to say and let's start
oh and also please interrupt me
aggressively okay
so here's what a lattice is we know this
from Daniela's talk this is just so you
can get used to my notation and my very
large dots so typically a lattice is
specified by basis B 1 through B n
here's the basis for this lattice the
lattice itself is a set of integer
linear combinations the basis vectors
and there's this very important story
geometric quantity on lattices which is
lambda 1 all right so this is lambda 1
of this lattice the length of that line
and it's the length of the shortest
nonzero vector right so this really
annoying issue comes up in sort of all
lattice algorithms and all that's
complexity results or at least
everything with SVP that like you have
to say nonzero right and this is the
bane of our existence like you'll see
you'll see later like SVP algorithms
they all they want to find a short
vector in a lattice and there's a really
good example of a short vector in a
lattice which is called zero and all the
work goes into having them still find a
short vector but somehow not finding
zero so I've already sort of said this
foot and Danieli define this
I'll be talking about the shortest
vector problem so the goal of the
shortest vector problem you're given a
lattice represented as a basis but we'll
sort of ignore issues like this and the
goal is to find a shortest nonzero
vector so the goal would be to find this
vector in this example provided I've
drawn this correctly there's also the
approximate version of the problem which
Daniele also defined so here we have
this approximation factor which I'll
typically charge as gamma and the goal
is just to find a nonzero lattice vector
whose length is within a factor gamma of
the best possible so maybe this is a
solution to like to approximate STP or
three approximate STP on this lattice
and I'll show you this I'll prove this
in the next talk but I'll just mention
for now that this problem is known to be
NP hard even for approximation and I'll
say a lot more about that in the next
talk but just so you get your bearings
like I'm going to be presenting you
algorithms for this problem they're not
going to run in polynomial time
because that would break complexity
theory okay and daniele sort of has this
nice question which is trying to guess
like which approximation factors I think
he was saying which approximation
factors you can solve efficiently but I
think another question is just the guess
what approximation factors are natural
for this problem I think it's not clear
at all like a lot of MP hard problems
sort of everything happens in like a
constant approximation factor regime and
what I I think what I'm really loved
about this problem is that it's
interesting for sort of all
approximation factors so like all the
way from 1 to 2 to the N they're
interesting results and you'll see quite
a few of them in this talk and and in
subsequent talks for crypto we care
about polynomial and N and this is not
obvious at all like why it should be
polynomial is not clear although some of
what Daniel II said kind of makes it
clear you might have noticed that in his
reductions between different lattice
problems he was losing like polynomial
factors like squared ends and ends this
is kind of where the polynomials come
from so I'm going to talk about SVP
basically entirely I'll just mention
that there are other lattice problems
and most of what I say holds for all of
these lattice problems and there's I
have a even more complicated diagram
than Daniele there's like many many
complicated relations in between I don't
expect you to interpret that at all
my point is simply that there's a lot
that I'm not going to talk about
particularly about other problems but
very roughly speaking all the algorithms
that I show you work for all of these
problems okay so that's like the
preliminaries here's what we're gonna do
first I'm going to show you algorithms
for the exact or near exact by near
exactly I mean a small constant
approximation factor these seem to
somehow be essentially the same problem
and then I'm going to show you the
approximation algorithms and the reason
I'm doing it in this order is because
our approximation algorithms use the
exact algorithms in the non-trivial way
okay so here's exact so I'm mostly going
to talk about Civic algorithms and
saving was introduced by haitai Kumar
and Shiva Kumar this is the picture that
Kumar puts on his website
I guess he's Tintin but this was this
major breakthrough algorithm you know
happening around the same time when I I
was proving worst case the average case
reductions and proving NP hardness they
also came up with the first singly
exponential time algorithm for SVP and
it uses a really really simple and
elegant idea so I make these slides by
hand
Daniele said it would be silly to do so
I do so okay so yeah here's how sevinc
works you sort of you start out with
some lattice it's represented by a basis
let's not worry about that the point is
that we can't find short points in
lattices that's hard what we can do we
can find long points not only can we
find long points we can find many many
long points how we get these like maybe
I take random small combinations of my
basis vectors or some
like this but I can find many points on
the lattice that are roughly the length
of my basis yeah and the idea behind
sippin is to observe that if you have
two lattice points that are if you know
two lattice points that are close
together then you can take their
difference and you'll get a short
lattice point or a short order lattice
point at least that's the whole idea so
the idea is to start out with these many
many lattice vectors and keep taking
pairs I got kind of excited by this
animation so I made too many but I guess
it hammers on the point you really need
to start out with a lot of them and you
keep taking pairs and notice that like I
didn't find a shortest vector by doing
this so two interesting things happened
here one I failed to find a shortest
vector and - I hit a collision right so
I found the same vector twice I got this
vector from this pair and from that pair
and these are both very relevant things
so okay so I'm not done this is not an
SCP algorithm yet it becomes an SVG
algorithm when we do it again right so
now I forget about all the red points
and now I'm gonna work on the purple
points I know many points that are
significantly shorter and I'll go again
and it happens that now like I find a
shortest vector in practice you run this
like polynomial many times and you'll
find a shortest vector necessary that
you get something structured by taking
the difference oh you throw away
anything that yeah yeah so I mean I was
about to say there are a lot of design
decisions right this is just a very
high-level framework for a sort of class
of algorithms which are known as sipping
algorithms in particular it's not clear
how you get the vectors to start out
with it's not clear what which pairs you
choose and it's not clear even how you
find pairs that are close together you
can imagine trying to do this more
efficiently than then brute-force search
so none of these things are clear and
there's just a ton of work sort of
instantiating all or answering all these
questions in different ways and trying
to get better algorithms that way okay
so I hope that's clear if I've lost you
now so what's amazing about saving is
that it
just an extraordinarily natural
technique like you just use the fact
that the difference of two lattice
vectors is also a lattice factor that's
like the only the only property you need
and there's a sense this kind of goes to
the nodes question but you can always
just sort of declare that I'll only take
differences of vectors that are like
shorter than all my current vectors or
something like this and in such a way
you can always just sort of clearly make
progress at each step every single step
you get shorter and shorter vectors and
the biggest pro of sippin is that it
actually does work but there's like a
really big Colin which is that it's very
very difficult to analyze this algorithm
and the reason that isn't hard to
analyze is because even if I start out
with some nice distribution maybe
uniform in a ball we would use the
discrete Gaussian even if I start out
with this nice distribution once I start
taking pairs that are close together and
subtracting them and then doing it again
and then doing it again the distribution
that we get is is some mess right like
you can't write it down it doesn't have
some simple closed-form as far as we
know and this is really unfortunate it's
kind of maddening because the only thing
that we need to do we need to know about
this distribution is that you don't get
collisions right so like by Fiat I'll
get shorter and shorter vectors at each
step so at some point my vectors will be
of length roughly lambda lon
the only issue is that maybe all my
short vectors are 0 at the end right um
so if we could just prove that this
algorithm somehow doesn't just find a
billion of the same vector um instead of
some nice variety of vectors then we'd
be good but all of the difficulty comes
in sort of ruling that out and there are
sort of three different ways sort of
paradigms for ruling it out the first is
the heuristic solution which mostly
Martin will talk about I'm going to talk
about provably correct algorithms but
the heuristic solution is to pretend
that this isn't an issue which is a
perfectly reasonable thing to pretend in
practice it doesn't happen so you just
assume that the vectors are distributed
nicely and perhaps not surprisingly this
gives the fastest possible algorithms
via saving if you assume that saving
works really really nicely
it does in fact work really really
nicely under your assumptions although
there's a tremendous amount of work in
this area because like making things
work out correctly even under this
assumption is so difficult in particular
like once you start assuming nice
distributions of your vectors you can
imagine using more efficient ways to
find pairs of clothes vectors and things
like this there's lots of great work on
that and I should say like for
cryptography this is what's relevant
right like we don't care kapag Rafi if
you can prove that your algorithm works
if it works in practice and it breaks
your crypto scheme and I'll say a little
bit more about heuristics but mostly I'm
leaving that I'm leaving you in the
hands of Martin the second solution is
what IKS originally did which is called
the perturbation solution or the
perturbation trick it's often referred
to us in the perturbation trick you add
noise to your vectors so instead of
working with the lattice vectors
themselves you jiggle them a little bit
and you jiggle them enough that you say
my algorithm didn't have enough
information about the real vectors that
I started with to find zero it's just as
likely to find zero as it is to find a
short vector so it's this very weird
sort of trick that makes the proof go
through where you lie to your algorithm
and because you lied to it you say
therefore it works you treat the
algorithm as an adversary and the last
sort of category is the one that I'll
talk about the most
it's called sippin by averages or that's
what I'm sometimes calling it and the
idea here is to like do something kind
of less natural but where we can
actually understand the distribution and
this was the work that Daniela was
talking about together with dvash who's
here Daniel do do shoes nod no dead reg
of who I think will be and I should say
this like I was inspired or as closely
related to two ideas for prior work so
before I show you the algorithm let me
just sort of tell you how these all how
these things all shake out at the end
so if you use the perturbation method
the best we know of is to to the 2.5 n
but stay tuned I'll kind of mention that
there's a there's a result that's not
very well known where you can get
significantly better if you're willing
to lose a little bit an approximation
factor the heuristics do much much
better they get to to the zero point two
nine n these are this is a hard for
thought constant and our sipping by
averages approach gets two to the N and
it kind of soared it gets two to the N
over two and I'll explain that later but
this is just sort of the high-level
picture and we're not done so the last
the last row is for you to fill in yeah
it's well algorithms running that time
whether they find a short vector or not
we don't know yeah so they think you may
run in that time and give you zero but
[Music]
yeah maybe you could flip it around if
you want I don't know okay so I'll talk
more about this living with that verjus
algorithm which was with dvash daniela
no dead
so the idea starts with a kind of silly
thought so suppose that instead of
taking differences of lattice vectors X
minus y I take averages X plus y over 2y
I don't know it's gonna end up working
out um so this is y okay but this is a
tremendously silly idea at first right
because like the average of two lattice
vectors is not typically going to be in
the lattice right so this is a bad idea
but it turns out that if you change it
slightly it works out nicely so we can
ask the question well when is this not
such a bad idea when does the average of
two lattice vectors land inside the
lattice and it helps to remember the
definition of a lattice here and sort of
write the two vectors that we're taking
the average of in terms of some basis B
1 through BN with their respective code
since these AI J's and then we can write
the average of course in terms of these
basis because everything's linear and
then you see that this will be a lattice
vector if and only if all of these
vectors all of these coefficients have
the same parity right so if you just
look at the parity of the coordinates
they should be the same for both y1 and
y2 the fancy way to say this is that why
one should be congruent to Y 2 modulo
twice the lattice and just a sort of
hammer the point home what I'm saying
here is that the average of two lattice
vectors lands in the lattice if and only
if y1 and y2 line the same co set of
twice the lattice and there are 2 to the
N Co sets that's where the running time
of the algorithm comes from so it's kind
of an important number here and the 2 to
the N comes from the fact that there are
2 to the N parity vectors and so here's
how the algorithm works literally so it
starts out the same as sitting we take a
bunch of lattice points that like aren't
too short sorry aren't too long but are
not as short as we'd like and then we
just look at one co set turns out that
these are all on the same co set and we
take their averages completely
arbitrarily so I don't look at what
length of vector I'm going to get it's
important that we don't look because if
we looked I wouldn't know how to analyze
the distribution so you don't look and
you just take averages so these are
these are the respective averages and
then you take another code you take the
next Co set you do the same thing you
take next go saying you the same thing
so the the full algorithm you start with
many vectors the actual distribution
that we use is kind of important you
start with the discrete Gaussian it was
the topic of my thesis not a big deal
but for each co set so you just sort of
go through the co sets and you group all
the vectors within the co set into
disjoint pairs it's important that you
do that arbitrarily um and then you take
the average of each pair and then you'll
have some new vectors and you just do it
again that's the algorithm defection I
refer to this as an embarrassingly
simple algorithm because we were
embarrassed to find
incredibly simple algorithm and so
here's the rough intuition for why this
should work I won't show you a proof but
the rough intuition for why it should
work is that at each step the average
vectors should go down by a factor of
square root 2 so this is actually true
the expected squared norm goes down by a
factor 2 formally the same thing
essentially right and this is just like
if you take the average of two random
vectors the result will have will be
shorter by a factor square root 2 but
all the magic is in the fact that we can
explicitly bound the probability of
collisions and that's because we know we
don't know the exact distribution that
we get by doing this but we know a
little bit about it and all you need to
know is just a tiny bit and we know
enough of a tiny bit in fact we know
quite a lot of course this algorithm
runs in time 2 to the N and has space
requirement 2 to the N which is pretty
unfortunate because there are 2 to the N
Co sets and sort of so the running times
just sort of dominated by the number of
vectors that you need to start with and
this is still the fastest algorithm for
SVP with proving correctness as I said
there are nice heuristic algorithms
which are significantly faster but one
thing that I'm very excited about is
that we can probably do better we can
probably make this work in 2 to the N
over 2 time and the way that you do that
is you just get a little more
sophisticated instead of being greedy
and saving a factor square root 2 every
time or going down by a factor square
root 2 every time I can just match
vectors with the same parity and roughly
half the coordinates and then I sort of
won't get a lattice vector but if I keep
doing it I'll eventually get back into
the lattice if that makes any sense um
but the idea is that like I work with 2
to the N over 2 Co sets instead of 2 to
the n Co sets and we sew this like
simple variant of this algorithm we
already know that it solves decision SVP
for a very small a constant proximation
factor and 2 to the N over 2 time and
get some kind of announcing this result
for the first time because it's not
written
but with dvash and leaves a only we
actually show that this works for her
meet SVP which daniela kind of defined i
think he called it minkowski SVP but
it's finding a lattice vector within
mini cow skis bound so this is the
formal statement for the experts in the
audience but the point is that like I
think the high-level picture is we have
a two to the n time algorithm and we're
pretty sure we have a two to the N over
two time to algorithm but we haven't
quite finished
proving that it works yet to the 0.82
algorithm there was also approximate
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yes so
this gets a worse approximation factor
but it's faster the to to the end of
course is exact yeah but I'll I have a
lot more to say about that algorithm
it's too busy on over - yes
so time and space both to the N over -
yes I think like first I do like the
first half of the coordinates then I do
the next half ah yeah just like over and
over and over again
and every one of these two steps reduces
the length device quitter - it just that
the first step doesn't land you in the
lattice yeah so you end up in like twice
the lattice or half the lattice or
something like that so you kind of lost
a factor - in the process
why this visit an intuition for why the
only source approximate so you did
decision SVP is supposed to this is
because really what we do is we compute
the smoothing parameter to really high
accuracy yeah
so that's not really it's because the
algorithm can work with bub smoothing
why why this is currently the best right
answer is just like that foot of proof
techniques give its biggest algorithm
stop you yeah so the algorithm finds
vectors at smoothing yeah yeah and you
can yeah you can check that they really
are what do you expect
[Music]
possibly across yes
square root at I mean so not not so
great
okay so first open problem please prove
that this algorithm works I'd be very
happy if someone did this and as I said
like it suffice is to prove almost
anything non-trivial about about the
algorithm and the version I have been
trying for about five years now and we
haven't we haven't quite managed yeah
good so suppose I did exactly half
matching right so if I matched half of
the coordinates divided by two and then
matched half of the coordinates divided
by two at the end I would land in the
lattice divided by two and my length
will also have gone down by a factor two
it's like square or two twice so that's
not great because you just sort of don't
make any progress but if I do n over two
plus a little bit than I do make
progress yeah so n over two is sort of
the where you start breaking even
I'd like to say just a little bit about
the heuristics living algorithms again
Martin's going to talk about these in
depth so the way that the sitting
algorithms work is you is you pretend
that your vectors are always uniformly
random on a sphere right so you're doing
this like sipping process you start out
with vectors that in fact are basically
uniformly round them on a sphere you do
this complicate procedure and you figure
that just always the case and this goes
back all the way to Fung and Thomas
Vivek actually and the important thing
about these swimming algorithms is that
you need the constraint on the running
time where everything comes from is that
you need four thirds to the N over two
vectors in order to have a good chance
of finding many closed factors you need
exponentially many and this is like a
simple calculation it might not look so
simple this is the number of vectors
that you need to have on a sphere before
random vectors they you down this here
before you expect to find two that are
very close together
once you find two that are very close
together you expect to find many and so
this is the constraint and the actual
running time is not quite as good as
this the actual running time that the
that the heuristic saving algorithms get
is is two to the zero point two nine n
so it's three halves to n over two new
set up for thirsty on over to see you
lose quite a bit and that's because you
still have to find pairs of close
vectors if you do that naively you'd
square the running time but if you're
that non naively using these
locality-sensitive hashing tricks you do
significantly better and there's a lot
of work trading off time and space and I
guess the last thing I want to say about
these algorithms I'm talking about this
for a reason it's gonna lead to an open
problem but the last thing I want to say
about these algorithms is it's not
entirely clear what problem they're
they're solving right like maybe it's
constant factor approximate SBP maybe
it's your Mead SVP maybe it's as IVP
it's really not clear for the lattices
that we run these on they're all the
same problem but
yeah but for arbitrary lattices they're
not as Daniele said okay so here's my
open problem number two open problem
number two is to find faster heuristic
quantum algorithms and I realized that
there's a lot of detail on this slide
but the point is that our current
fastest quantum algorithms also use this
very large number of vectors and they
use quantum tricks to find pairs faster
but this means that they'll never run
faster than 4/3 the N over two time and
this is what governs the quantum
security of lattice paste crypto this
constant so if you can improve this
constant well first of all do it now
don't do it three years from now because
take you from an academic to an attacker
but also it would just be really cool
and really important and I think that
there's like a fairly abstract way to
view this which is I give you Oracle
access to points on a sphere and the
goal is just to find a sum of them
that's a little shorter than the points
that you started with that's it so I
think it's like a very clean question
random points on a sphere and if you can
solve this in time faster or okay yeah
in time faster than for three to the N
over 2 then modulo some minor details
you can probably solve SVP in the same
time so this is a problem that I think
people should be thinking about it as
far as I know basically nobody is yet
yeah you're accusing exactly this
[Music]
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so I'm
ignoring the time-space trade-off
algorithms because they get less time
I'm just trying to tell a simpler story
but yes yes that could be a direction
yeah yeah that's it so yeah so if you
instead of taking pairs of vectors you
take say triples or you know four tuples
or whatever then there exists is a
Damien has work on this Elena has work
on this a lot of people have worked on
this trading off time for space and one
can imagine that in the quantum world
that that would work out better that's
actually a really good direction but
seems weird to make it an open problem
because lots of people are working on it
all right
apparently lots of people working on
this or at least laio is Oh more
questions
so now I'll say a little bit about the
last method so this is the original
algorithm the AKS algorithm use the
perturbation method remember yes yeah
you tell me what happens if you run them
on practice on some well designed
lattices yeah I mean it depends right
because like what's a constant factor
approximation when you're in you know 60
dimensions or whatever there are some
issues but no I think this is a I'm not
leaving this as an open question yeah I
think it's just an interesting thing to
think about I mean in practice it
doesn't matter right but when you're
trying to sort of categorize these
things it does
Hey so for your algorithm that taking
averages this is a non-starter unless
you have to to the end no not that I
know of like you can try taking triples
which a lot of people have suggested but
that seems to really not work yeah so as
far as I know of like our current
provable techniques are stuck at two to
the N over two which is unfortunate
because you know this number is smaller
than that we'd like to just match the
heuristics but that that seems out of
reach three that's little but then you
don't get a reduction in length there
are a lot of issues that call okay so
first of all it's not clear what the
right generalization is do you use code
sets of three L or 2l instead of solving
to some you solve threesome that's a
pain yeah yeah that's the biggest issue
I think
so the perturbation method which was the
original method is just to add a little
bit of noise to to your lattice point so
fool your algorithm is the idea and for
exact SVP the perturbation based methods
the best the best algorithm is by
daniele and vulgaris that runs in 2 to
the 5 and time sorry this is wrong this
is a 2 to the 2 point 5 n time and 2 to
the 1 point 2 5 in I doubled instead of
having but what I want to talk about is
that the fastest prefer that there's a
constant factor approximate algorithm so
what I want to talk about is this
algorithm which is originally due to Lu
Wang zulan zheng which runs in two to
the zero point eight zero to end time
so faster than it's two to the n time
algorithm but it only solves for
constant factor approximate SVP in fact
for a very large approximation factor
they go under there something actually
de very nice write-up of this algorithm
sort of looking at it from a more modern
perspective it's a very clean algorithm
it's basically just say K yes but what I
want to talk about is where this
constant comes from so this is the best
known upper bound on the kissing number
which is the number of vectors that you
can place on a sphere that are all at
most distant at least distance one apart
and that's sort of a natural bound on
sipping algorithms because if sitting
out because if you don't have enough
points to even see two that are close
then obviously you can't sieve right so
this is the famous kava Chomsky
Levenstein bound that hasn't been
improved since 1978 and seems very very
difficult but I want to make a point
which is that if you just make a purely
geometric conjecture that the kissing
number is this 4 thirds to the N over 2
which is the best lower bound that we
know
and plausibly true then I think you
actually get approval bleah where
provable means under a purely geometric
conjecture you don't assume anything
about the algorithm you get a 430 in
over to switch them again for if there's
the N over 2 space 4/3 to the end time
algorithm for SVP
this actually works out checking with
device yeah and my open question which
might be is provable yeah yeah cool
right it's it's I mean it's my
observation I don't know if other people
have also made the same observation I
don't think it's written down anywhere
yeah
the original paper it's under different
assumption I say I say I say yeah is
this provable and is it provable
untraditionally it's provable under a
conjecture on the kissing number 5 so
you can prove it that's the specimen
number dated 1 is the square of the
kissing number for whatever yeah you can
just drop in the kissing number yeah
it's slightly more complicated than
kissing number it's like the hugging
number or something like if they don't
have to all be exactly on a sphere they
can be a little office here but
basically it's that usually when you
bound the kissing number you get that 2
was already then Pete then the paper
document yeah yeah this space yeah yeah
but the space is heuristic I think oh I
see I see um here's my open problem
which i think is low-hanging fruit which
is just like complete the circle right
so we have this under a purely geometric
conjecture we have this 4/3 to the n
time algorithm that used for Thursday
and over to space and this is kind of
what the heuristic algorithms do they
also have for Thursday in over to space
but they do a little better because they
use this locality-sensitive hashing to
get the running time down quite
considerably to 2 to the 0.29 n so a
really natural looking question I think
is can you just use this
locality-sensitive hashing technique
there and maybe then immediately we'd
have like something that's almost as
good as the heuristic algorithms or no
it's just as good the here stick
algorithms with much less assumptions is
Tyson the audience he should solve the
problem someone else can solve it too
okay open problem number 4 is kind of
the obvious one which is just prove that
you can do as well as heuristics this
this seems harder so this would be
unconditionally and now I'll just say a
little bit
about algorithms that are not sitting on
rhythms so Ravi in the audience so the
sort of the first exact SVP algorithm
one of the first was due to Kanaan in
1987 and the idea here is quite natural
you you look at the gram-schmidt vectors
that daniela was talking about before
and you just sort of observe that if a
lattice vector is going to be short then
its last coordinate can't be very large
because if it's last coordinate we're
larger than there'd be some direction or
be sticking out too much so you use that
observation to bound the last coordinate
and then you say for every last
coordinate within that bound what bound
do I get on the second-to-last
coordinate and what bound do I get in
the third to last coordinate etc etc etc
and you keep going and you don't just
find the shortest lattice vector you
find sort of all vectors within some
some small ball so these this is a very
nice technique it runs an end to the end
time from a theoretical perspective the
most interesting thing about is that it
runs in polynomial space there's a ton
of work on improving on this on
different variants that get the run time
better some heuristic some exact and
depending on who you ask I think this is
still the fastest technique in practical
dimension so like for example I think
all the current has VP challenges like
the highest dimensions so now there's
this Jessica paper it's a that it just
changed it just changed so sitting just
beat enumeration like a month ago or
something but it's still what's used
quite a bit in practice important
algorithm and the other algorithm which
is completely out of left field it's
just as really beautiful algorithm by by
daniele and vulgaris who does not have a
picture online so this is an artist's
interpretation they have just a
completely different algorithm it's sort
of somehow much more geometric than all
these other ones it uses the Voronoi
cell of the lattice which is a really
beautiful object and as Daniela said it
runs in four
the end time so not quite as good as the
fastest approvable that we have two to
the n space so it ties there it's also
really kind of magical because it's
deterministic and of course the sipping
algorithms are not they're sort of the
whole point is that they're randomized
so this is really quite surprising and
beautiful and and the obvious open
question here which has been open for
for a bit this might be hard is to show
that Machon Tova Garris works in 2 to
the N time but that's just for the
experts I'll not even show the algorithm
in summary the status of exact near
exact STP for exact or small constant or
constant approximation factor the best
provable that we have is 2 to the N
we're pretty sure that we can get our
provable techniques down to 2 to the N
over 2 o heuristic Li we can do like
pretty significantly better a 2 to the
0.29 n and of course this is very
important because this is what governs
the security of Latta space crypto so
soon it's going to sort of be what we
run the internet on and this these you
sipping and I have this I just want to
mention that it's possible that we can
get this under purely geometric
conjectures which i think would be
pretty cool there's also these two other
algorithms which are harder to
categorize there's much on trouble
Garris which runs it forward at the end
time and there's this whole class of
algorithms enumeration which is
interesting because it runs a polynomial
space and also because it works quite
well in practice ok
so now I'll move on to approximately
so the first lives algorithm you should
learn but I had to do in a different
order annoying reasons is is the lol
algorithm due to two lunches in the
lavash from 1982 this is the most
important lattice algorithm it was a
massive breakthrough at the time it has
applications just all over the place but
when you first see it it's not clear why
it should be useful at all um it's
interesting so to understand the
algorithm I think the best thing to do
is to think about SVP first in just two
dimensions so Daniela mentioned that in
two dimensions SVP is easy he didn't
show you an algorithm I will it's not so
hard it's actually quite beautiful and
you have this algorithm well you have
two basis vectors we want to be two and
the algorithm just sort of has two
desires it wants v1 to be shorter than
v2 seems reasonable and it also it just
wants it to be the fact that the case
that if I add B 1 or subtract B 1 from B
2 it shouldn't get any longer that's it
and it turns out that if those two
properties are satisfied by your basis
then B 1 is a shortest vector this is
true in two dimensions it's very much
not true in higher dimensions and
actually proving this requires a little
bit of case analysis it's not so obvious
I'll show you a proof in a bit that it
gets a decent approximation factor so
the way the algorithm actually works is
you start out with your basis I like to
write it as a matrix and you see this
basis the first sky is longer than the
second guy and we don't like that so the
first thing that you do is you just swap
them so there's two kinds of steps
there's a swamp step that sort of fixes
this problem or enforces this condition
and then now if you look at this basis
you realize that I can subtract off this
vector from this vector and it will be
shorter in fact I can do it many times
and I will this is called size reduction
I just subtract off as many of the first
vector from the second vector as I can
while still making it shorter so now I
have quite a short vector and if you
just do this I guess you do two more
operations one more swap one more reduce
you see that I actually started with the
integer lattice
but this is the algorithm daniela
attributed it to Lagrange's you see
attributed to Gauss I trust Kenya
daniele on this I see I see I see I see
think gas has better habits commonly
attributed to God yeah from Yentl may be
found in the coal normale superiore
library the original man I see I think
neither of them need the credit yes so
this is and you'll notice this is just
the Euclidean algorithm right I mean
this is just a sort of little
modification you click Malcolm I think
actually with the vectors that I chose
it's literally the occluding algorithm
in the top part in the first coordinate
so ll tries to sort of generalize this
idea I in order to generalize it it
really really helps to think of this
algorithm slightly differently in
particular it helps to think about the
gram-schmidt vectors so in two
dimensions the gram-schmidt vectors
there's really just one that's
non-trivial the first one is just be one
so remember Danieli define this this is
the same definition that this is the
same object slightly different
definition but B 2 tilde is what I'll
call a gram-schmidt vector and it's just
the orthogonal part of B walk of b2 from
b1 right so I can write B 2 tilde as
something times v1 plus something
orthogonal to B 1 and B 2 tilde is the
orthogonal part good so I could rewrite
these conditions just in terms of this
so if I have mu to be my component in
the B one direction or my like the
multiple that I have to add on b1 and I
have my B 2 tilde then I can write my
length of B 2 B 2 squared as norm of B 2
tilde squared plus mu times norm of B 1
squared
tygris
so this condition becomes this condition
in this condition just becomes that Mew
should be an absolute value of most to
half right because if nu is larger than
1/2 then I can subtract if Mew is
less than minus 1/2 then I can add and
I'll make the vector shorter right and
it's nice to think about what this
algorithm is sort of how these values
interact with basic lattice quantities
so first of all the determinant says
they only mentioned is the product of b1
times b2 so you're always going to have
those the same as you do your basis
production algorithm but lambda 1 of the
lattice length our short Specter it
can't be more than a b1 of course
because B one's a lattice vector but it
has to be at least either B 1 or B 2
tilde the minimum of the two you see why
it's kind of what I was saying earlier
right so either your shortest vector has
a nonzero component in the b2 tilted
direction or it doesn't if it has a
nonzero component in the B 2 tilde
direction then it has to be at least
length B 2 tilde and if it doesn't have
a something in that direction then it's
clearly length B 1 so it's nice about
this is it suggests that the way you
should think about basis reduction is
you try to make these two bounds of meet
and the fact that this is constant means
really what you're trying to do is make
b1 as close to b2 as possible that's the
goal B to tilde as possible so that's
sort of a better way to think of
galaxies or Lagrange's algorithm and in
particular just using this you can kind
of immediately see that this algorithm
gives you a route 4/3 approximation
factor this route 4/3 it's the same
route 4/3 from before it's not obvious
but you can see that the norm of B 1 has
to be at most route 4/3 Norma b2 that
follows from these two inequalities I
just plug in you most a half there and
then by this this means that the norm of
B 1 is at most root 4/3 times lambda 1
is that check out okay so L algorithm
just generalizes this idea so you start
out now with a full basis and you can
define the gram-schmidt says Danielle I
did as bi tilde will be
tilda is going to be bi projected
orthogonal to all the vectors before it
and a nice way to think about this when
you're doing basis reduction is to
imagine you do a change of coordinates
so that your basis is upper triangular
and then the gram-schmidt Tsar just the
diagonals so like formally here the
change of coordinates is just why don't
I call b1 the x-axis and why wouldn't I
call B to tilde the X 2 axis and B 3
tilde X 3 axis and then you'll get this
nice hyper triangular matrix and I've
generalized them you that I had earlier
now I have these mu I J's for the
component of the jate vector in the X
direction and the two properties of the
of the gram-schmidt that I showed for in
two dimensions generalized so lambda one
of the lattice is at least the minimal
length of any of the gram-schmidt and
the proof is exactly the same it has to
have a non zero coordinate somewhere and
the determinant is the product of the
gram-schmidt so the way that the LML
algorithm works is to just generalize
the condition that we have before for
for two dimensions into many dimensions
and specifically you work with the
gram-schmidt you work with these little
blocks along the diagonal these two by
two blocks along the diagonal of your
your upper triangular matrix and you
just enforce the condition this
condition just says that be ice bi tilde
squared should be minimal conditioned on
this block right so this just says like
this should be a solution to SDP or this
should be a solution to SB p in this
little block not the whole lattice but
in this little block so yeah this is
making sure that the first vector is as
short as possible and the same analysis
that I did before still goes through
this implies just these two conditions
together by just subbing in half for mu
IJ you see that the norm of BI tilde
can't be much larger than the norm of BI
plus 1 tilde the way we tip
we phrase this is that the gram-schmidt
vector shouldn't decay too rapidly the
norms shouldn't go down too fast and if
you just sort of apply this many times
you see that actually b1 has to be at
most the 4/3 to the N over 2 times B I
tilde there should be a minimum over all
I FB I tilde and then because the
minimum over all I bi tilde is a bound
on lambda 1 this means that this gives
you a 432 the N over 2 approximation to
the shortest vector which doesn't sound
that good right oh but it turns out that
this is extraordinarily useful I'm not
going to discuss the uses but this is
incredibly useful algorithm and I'll
just mention if you actually want to
implement this algorithm you you have to
change this inequality slightly you have
to add a little quantity Delta here
that's less than 1 because otherwise the
algorithms not knowing determining but
morally this is what's going on and I
haven't exactly said the algorithm let
me just sort of say it outright what the
algorithm does it tries to satisfy these
two conditions so first it checks if
condition 2 is not satisfied the
condition 2 is not satisfy it just fixes
it by this size reduction right by
subtracting off like bi from BJ or
whichever way is correct if 1 is not
satisfied then you just swap bi with the
I plus 1 so it's really just sort of
this two-dimensional algorithm run on an
n dimensional lattice just looking at
these 2d blocks and you repeat this
until reduced and you can prove that the
algorithm terminates in polynomial time
pretty easily with this Delta just by
showing that it makes non-trivial
progress at each step in some sense the
shorter vectors are getting earlier at
each step that's kind of what this is
doing and if you define the
appropriative potential function then
then the proofs quite quick so just to
say what we proved in 433 on over to SDP
is in polynomial time so that was the
answer to the danyele's question from
before it turns out the answer is
exponential not obvious at all
so now let me tell you about important
generalization of the Helliwell
algorithm which is the bkz algorithm bkz
stands for block Corkins a lot too rough
it's not a very good name its historical
what no but the the Corkins alerts are
of like okay that's a specific kind of
basis so this is like a block version of
that yeah it's not clear that okay I
just said it ignore me because II rolls
off the tongue I just I have trouble
saying the Z person so okay lol the idea
is look at these little two by two
blocks and make the first vector as
short as possible
um snore I guess five years later or at
least was published five years later
said um what if we look at K by K blocks
instead two by two blocks and this turns
out to be L algorithm was a really good
idea this is also a really good idea I
wrote it here so when you look at K by K
blocks the idea is still to enforce this
condition that we've previously
enforcing on two by two blocks which is
to make the first vector as short as
possible in your K by K block there's no
longer simplifies to like these two
simple lavash conditions that I showed
you earlier but it's still meaningful so
I could just make sure that the first
vector the first gram-schmidt in each
block is as short as possible given the
block so this is called a BK z reduced
basis and the BK z algorithm which i'll
put in scare quotes because there are
many ways to instantiate it the idea is
just to use a k-dimensional SVP oracle
so you have you assume you have a solver
for sv p in dimension K and you look at
these blocks that are K by K and if you
find a vector that's shorter than your
current gram-schmidt then you replace it
by you
then you replace your current Graham
shrimp by the new vector and you have to
like update the basis and there's like
an lol reduced process that you have to
do to make sure you have numerical
stability but this is the idea and you
repeat this until you're reduced so you
should think of this as a reduction from
approximate SVP in n dimensions to exact
SVP in K dimensions in fact this is the
main use case I think of SVP algorithms
exact SUV algorithms it's not to solve
exact ICP itself it's to solve
approximate SBP via this reduction the
algorithm as I described it is not
actually known to terminate in
polynomial time this is should or
suggested this algorithm but didn't know
how to prove we still don't know how to
prove that it works you can prove that
it does pretty well in a various ways
but there's lots of work that tries to
instantiate this idea in a whole variety
of different ways I'm going to tell you
basically about one of them sort of
about two so the current
state-of-the-art improvable SVP
algorithm so just like in the exact case
in the approximate case there here is
tic algorithms and there approvable
algorithms the state of the art for
provable is due to nickel on prong all
the way back in 2008 they show a
provable variant of BK z and it's it's
very beautiful it can be depicted like
this the idea is to take your upper
triangular matrix and divide it into
blocks just like before so here I have
like blue blocks and dotted red blocks
and I'm going to do different things in
these blue blocks and the red blocks the
blue blocks I'm gonna SVP reduce so the
first vector that I've shaded here is
going to be as short as possible in the
red blocks I'm gonna do something kind
of funny in the last though I'm gonna
make the last gram-schmidt vector in the
red block as long as possible which
maybe isn't that funny if you remember
that kind of like our final goal is to
make the gram-schmidt snot decay too
quickly so it's kind of natural to take
the to make the last gram-schmidt vector
in a block as large as possible and it
turns out that this is actually
equivalent to STP
solving that problem is just like
solving SVP but in the dual lattice of
the block and as opposed to the lattice
itself yeah
and so what Phong and Nicola did is they
sort of staggered these blocks you'll
notice this this is very very elegant
because the blocks that they chose like
all the blue blocks are disjoint and all
the red blocks are disjoint the only
overlap is sort of between blue and red
box and this makes the algorithm very
very clean to analyze these are just the
definitions which I can say I told you
and I'll give you a complete analysis of
the fact that this solves STP and I'll
show you the approximation factor let it
go because it's not so hard so notice
that the fact that my blue blocks are
reduced means that the first vector in
the block is at most square root K times
the determinant of the block normalized
appropriately this is minkowski's
theorem that Daniele showed you and you
can write to determine through the block
of course as the product of the
gram-schmidt so we're kind of using the
two things that we know here and the
dual conditions the fact that the last
vector in a dual block is long well they
you can apply Minkowski to the dual and
you'll get that the last vector in the
block is large relative to determinants
of the block and you get this square K
in the denominator that's just Makowski
on the dual and again you can write this
determinant as a product and you notice
that these products are shifted off by
one and then you just divide one product
by the other and everything magically
cancels maybe not so magically I don't
know and you see that when you go from
the first vector we went that when you
jump by K so when you go from one block
to the next block
you'll lose essentially a factor K in
the gram-schmidt so the gram-schmidt can
decay by most effector K and this means
up to the fact that I only have this
inequality for
first vectors and blocks this means that
my norm of B 1 is at most K to the N
over K actually it's an minus K because
there and minus K over K blocks this is
just me applying this many times times
the norm of the gram-schmidt which means
that I get a K to the N minus K over K
approximation so this is the this is the
the headline result we can reduce SVP
with this approximation factor
essentially K to the N over K to SVP
exact SVP in dimension K and that's kind
of the only way we know how to 1
essentially the only way we know how to
solve approximate SBP oh and something
to note is that this is actually a
generalization of LOL so remember then
the lll algorithm we only had one kind
of block we looked at these two by two
blocks but notice that for two by two
blocks because the product of B 1 and B
2 is fixed making B 2 as large as
possible is the same as making B 1 as
small as possible so in some sense this
is sort of a counterintuitive
generalization of hello well that works
pretty nicely
yes so the headline result is that K to
the N over K SVP and dimension and
reduces to CP in dimension K there's a
little bit of a restriction that K has
to be at most n over 2 and this is a bit
abstract it helps to sort of plug in
examples if you plug in K to be some
constant times n then you get a
polynomial you get some polynomial and n
here that's what's relevant for
cryptography great
so cryptography we care about polynomial
approximation factors which means we
need K to be you know and over ten or
something like this I guess usually
quite a bit higher than that which means
that we're still going to run in
exponential time but the constant is
going to depend on what polynomial we
need if you plug in K equal log in or
order log n even then you'll get 2 to
the N log log n over log n so you'll get
a little bit better than the 2 to the
end that we got from LOL and it'll still
run in polynomial time because we can
solve this SVP in time two to the K
which is polynomial in practice K equals
ten is like pretty useful um that just
gives you a exponential factor but the
constant and the base is quite small and
here I said it so this is this is
actually the best result we know they
can practice if you want to run in
polynomial time maybe you just run LOL
but if you want to be fancy you can save
this poly log factor there's another
well there are a few other provably
correct basis reduction algorithms I
just want to highlight one by daniele
and Michael we're both here which is the
dual bkz algorithm it doesn't look so
nice in this notation but the idea
behind their algorithm is just SVP
reduce and do less VP reduce everything
and this is a really nice algorithm
because it's very similar to what's
actually used in practice both in
performance and the in what it's doing
the unfortunate thing about is that's
only known to prove to solve her meet
SVP so it's only known to find a vector
that's short relative to determinate not
necessarily short relative to lambda one
yeah so in Ellie's right there instead
of this light in the window down and
just different from the beginning you
get backwards and you yeah backward
we're doing a dualist repeat and if
you'd rather than you can get better
provable results or you can see and it
achieves the same approximation as light
without that I got in the Hermitage and
you can also give general reductions
from a hermit from SP right right when
you bet you lose you don't get as good
approximate square he was an extra
square root and oh yeah there's the yeah
yeah yeah
somehow yeah it's an interesting the
excursions interesting but yeah
so summary of all this is just this one
slide which is that K to the N over K
approximate lattice problems SVP also
most other lattice problems reduces to
exact SVP in dimension K as I said this
is kind of why mostly why we care about
so I think I'm fairly close to done am I
supposed to be fairly close to done okay
I but I want to list some more open
problems so one open problems I think is
really interesting is the following can
we solve approximate SVP just in some
other way
like the only way we know the only game
in town right now is essentially basis
reduction which means reducing the
approximate problem to the exact problem
and I think will be really interesting
just to show a different way to do it
even if it's not better than our current
methods just to show that we have
another idea I mean like you know
Helliwell was 1982 time for anyway yeah
next open problem is yes and this works
yeah yeah yeah yeah I view that as the
same thing yeah so that's why I have my
near exact here place the block by not
exact but approximate yeah that works
but you yeah you is like a yeah like a
gamma to the N over carrier yeah yeah we
actually we wrote that down and yeah
No oh yeah yeah yeah yeah okay you can
so we have this like one constant factor
approximate via the perturbation method
algorithm so there's an example but
basically yeah okay like it's Turtles
all the way down right
uh if you're eventually going to just
reduce to SVP it'll be really nice to
just have something else there are like
a few examples of like you know CVP with
pre-processing where we have different
ideas and things like this but not just
for SDP and it'll be really cool to find
something
okay the next question is more specific
it's just can we solve square root n SVP
faster than exact or near exact STP
right now as far as I know the proof of
the best provable algorithm for square
root and SDP is the same as the fast
approval algorithm for exact STP we have
this two to the N over two thing but
morally morally it doesn't count and
this is this is really strange and this
is kind of because of minkowski's
theorem we pay a square root n at the
outset when we do block reduction so we
either need to do block reduction in the
in a more clever way or we need an
entirely new idea and a spoiler for an
open problem from the next talk I want I
would love to show that basis reduction
can be reversed right so I'm asking can
we solve these approximate out problems
in a different way if you could show me
the basis reduction works in the reverse
direction as well then the answer would
essentially be no right if you can
reduce the approximate problem let's see
if I get this right
if you can reduce the exact problem in
small dimensions to the approximate
problem in larger dimensions then you've
shown that the two problems are
equivalent not just a reduction in one
direction so that would be really cool
but we have we do know something like
this the tensor in trick which I'll
mention in the next talk we know
anything is strong is sort of what we
would need to show that these two are
equivalent
their major complexity theoretic
barriers but I still think thinking
about this problem
okay okay that's my reduction of search
to search in action or or a decision to
decision I guess it's just decision to
decision yeah question the vector in the
high level needs to be a pencil oh yeah
it doesn't have to be yeah yeah oh
that's a good question yeah okay so
maybe we don't have any tricks that work
fully for this
yeah okay so here's my full list of Oh
some problems and I used like skiing
notation uh-huh
I don't ski so I guess like there's
low-hanging fruit I tried to include one
piece of low-hanging fruit I think this
is low-hanging as far as I know it's
still not been picked which is fun and I
think some of these problems are
potentially easy some of them are
obviously quite difficult like finding a
faster quantum algorithm for sitting but
yeah and this will be available online
so you can look at leisure but now I
think I'm okay I'm done
thumbs up also I'm on the job market
[Applause]
during the government data distribution
of different hydration
I think the answer is like I mean you
can write it down but I don't think like
you get a nice distribution after one
stuff
I mean you write down just because like
it's a convolution of two things in a
conditional right so like yeah but I
don't think it's nice in any way yeah
and of course sitting after one step is
not okay if you do the averaging trick
at any point you're never gonna get
below two to the N over two so as far as
I know so I don't know that that's very
useful bit
yeah I mean understanding and like
finding other ways to sieve while you
still know what the distribution is or
know something about the distribution I
think is a promising direction
so what you need to prove you out
whether you the average in algorithm you
decide you don't need to maintain a
discrete Gaussian all the way but that
would be zero just show that doesn't
give you too many zeros that's it I mean
yeah I mean I I know the expected norm
if it just if you don't get zero too
much then it has to give you a short
vector but it could be the case that the
algorithm finds a bunch of zeros and a
bunch of really long vectors and nothing
in between I we don't know how to rule
that out it's yes algorithms too simple
and we don't know how to analyze it yeah
what about other norms beside it - so
the my Gaussian so they go well with it
- yes yeah so I'm gonna I'm gonna talk
about other norms more in the next talk
because we got things for them but yeah
so I mean you know this already but
there's two to the order n time sippin
algorithms in every norm now but the
constants have mostly not been worked
out devices are very nice paper on
sippin in the old fitna norm where they
get a quite impressive constant yeah I
think there's just been there's been
some work but a lot less work and like
not this like whole sequence of works
getting better and better constants and
I think it's a worthy goal especially
since like in crypto often we don't
really use the LCR
hit me
but Rankin versus dimensions Allah in l2
there is no difference yeah yeah yeah so
so the lower bound is that we know which
I'll talk about in the next lecture are
in terms of the rank and the upper
bounds are in terms of the dimension for
all the you know
well okay 2 to the order n we can do for
any norm so when you can do it for any
norm you can you can respect to a
subspace right so their dimension and no
I mean if I can I'll change the norm but
if I can do it for any norm I can do it
for any norm
yeah yeah but like in the context where
we're trying to get constants I think
everything's in terms of
so you talk about this VP algorithm yeah
so did so for exact CVP the the a DRS
algorithm the sieve in by averages not
as described but a variant of it
actually does solve exact STP and
Daniela's algorithm the 4 to the n
machado vulgaris algorithm also solves
exact STP and basically any result you
can get this is hand wavy but sort of
any saving result for SVP kind of
immediately gives you a constant factor
approximate CVP in practice not not
there's no reduction or anything so the
results are broadly similar for CVP in
Euclidean norm yeah yeah actually in
other norms as well
we have approximate saving for all LP
norms not known for all norms but if you
want exact CBB in that once any out of
infinity and to the ends of us we know
okay so a little push on you for typical
letters how anti concentrated is the
distribution of the shorter Spectre
sorry I don't understand what it's like
is there is would I expect a wide range
of values for the service sector oh oh
if you take a random lies it's a very
very very high leakage
yeah so the way the way to think about a
random lattice is a shape of volume one
should have one point in it an
expectation it does an expectation right
so if I go from volume 1 of a ball of
volume 1 and I multiply it by 2
then I expect to have two to the end
points in there so like you're certainly
get at least one point in there I guess
like it should be scale-invariant the
approximation factor so I think so I
think multiplicative multiplicative is
what makes sense
okay so there are questions we'll resume
at 3:30
[Applause]
[Music]